今日は外れ山頂です皆さん人をダメにするソフ
持っています僕はちょっと話題になってくるに人をダメにするソファを言って買って
そこからハマっちゃってダメになってを買ってダメになっても勝ってこれが f 生活
できないくらいの人間になってしまいましたかつて
いや今をだと思うんですけど超低反発がこの身体が埋もれていく感じにより
菅野1地獄に叩き落としダメ人間を作りに作り作りまくった悪の根源そんな素敵な人が
水相談なんですけども私は気づいてしまいましたサイズがあるんですよ m サイズと
l サイズかってことはですよ
サイズがあるということはワールドワイドな目線で見てみるとめちゃくちゃでかい人だ
ムース底打ってんじゃねーかと思いましてねじゃあ去年ぐらいからずっと
海外のサイトとかで人をダメにするソファのめちゃくちゃでかいパンションが売って
ないかなと思って調べたんですけども
あげましたそれももうで敵デビューですよはいこちらでどうぞ
はい
レギュラーえっイヤーやわけですかこれこれだとに本当にもヤバいと思って絶対可能と
思ったんですよ
なんで見て見て見て
もうお風呂やピューためにするソファーとなるこう頭でクッションみたいな感じなん
ですけどもこんなにも大きいことがあるのか
僕は目を疑いましたですが前日に海外のサイトに売っていたのです
など海外の売ってるクッションを日本で取り寄せてくれるサイトとかがあってそちらで
凍っていただいたんですけども
続
いきましょう
ガー10局ソファーとがクッションのが別途って大きければいいともじゃないですから
ね彼には俺はね新しいのカードがあれば世界で一番大きい人をダメにするソファを見て
みたかっただけなんですよ
これか
思ってる小さく2回り目がほんとさぁある人はこうやって乗ったからたもっと
ざーみたいに水んだというか思ってる小さいですよあなた大丈夫
悦めでたいと思って構える皆さん教えてくださいまだ慌てる時間じゃありません開会
から届いているということは圧縮圧縮
から密封されてグーってなってこのサイズで届いたのかもしれません
開けてみる
とわからないんですけどもう大丈夫なんか保護さればかりようなところがあるとすぐに
思ってみようと思います違う
思うあの皆さん
これ
圧縮されています重さがやばいですから体幹今500強ぐらいありました
これこれどう自分に運ぶんだから冷蔵庫でちょっと重い
いやホームでは絵を用いてみろせたを進んでいきましょう
tan
はなめっ澤井まあ
なんとしますピぐわぁーっ peter man who 徒歩では待ってこれダメ
一人で持ってい
油がヤバイまたは山ですほんじゃなく
a
うーんこれさぁ待って危ないはダイガー
ただけではないがー
だけど
エーシンですねはーい jr
すっごい are you doing
yeah yeah
はいするか通ったというわけでさっそく開封していきましょう
ああーー
th
うわあああっはああああ
ます
dj
まだの一瞬あったドイツがねはまりにはがせるね俺
えーなんか変あれこんなんだって柄分けてみますねガーゼで子です
をでもずっとみてくださちゃんと説明書にはこのサイズ書いてあります汚れすぎだなぁ
このサイズ感おかしいなんでだ私の推移によるとこれを何とかして大きく誰だと思うん
ですよねまったくわからんですけど多分そんな気がしますめっちゃ硬いですよこれよと
もこれ
流れるぞできます
左本てるとやれよそんなシーズンが寄せいただきます
まあやっぱりだそういうことかめちゃくちゃ圧縮してありますねこれ圧縮した人なら
なかったぞ2月はこちら見なく際完全に圧縮食べてますねこれもうこれは多分キハだっ
たらメッツ大きくなるんだと思いますもう
うわぁ midi 金子なぁ出力はこんな出力はね俺でもヤバいと分かります
ものすごい急
されますこれクッションカバーなんですけども
どうしましょう朝食もが密封されているうちにクッションカバーに入れてれたあとに
これ破ってポンテがたまたま来な気がするんだよねまだでグっしょんがぁのを今
ラバえりゃーこの大きな私はバカじゃないのでまず最初にいれば滅でかくなるでしょ
そんなんでどうも5回参考例ができる男の違いよもう先に作れちゃいます
大半が割れな運転サイズは大きくなったクッションに胸にこれをかを移そうとする者
小さいうちにかぶせと
ぞ
はいまあなぜなくってことですせは早速アン祝解放していきましょう
怖い夜こんなには仕方した人見たことだけができま
えっもう開いてねっ
でもアイゼンじゃあどういうこと
ば宿されてないよねその3打目で触らないでそういうことこれねこれどうなってんだ
なんて一体
ちょっとわからないですねどういうことなんでしょうかまったく話がわかなく引っ張っ
たのビルですよなんで何か間違えた私
ピュア be back チャージドリーマーズビッセ4の覚えて in size
is 分こわいなん
あるタイプカバー s blue 全パリティペイジー合わせていますですか
やば英語読めて良かったねこれもすべてが圧縮させられたらしいんですよ届いた後に元
のサイズに戻るまで死後日語るって書いてありますねこれ嘘や
まんちーはー
[音楽]
思ったより大きくなったら声 why お前
3日前までこんなんだったのに3日にこんなことに何か
えーすごいて待ちますっていうか3日経ったんですけど3日でたらもう一番大きい
サイズなので膨らみましたアンナ小さかったの
こんなになっちゃったんですよねほんとでかいいよこれ普通の酒盗だりする
オファーなんですけど見て下さいこのサイズのさんこんなことある
ホットケーキに乗ってるまたよいやほんとでか言ってあったというわけで本当に前買っ
てきてびっくりしてですけど
アースクってすごいですけど3日のでまだちょっと大きくなると思うけども完全に完全
に根菜ですね
絵本としてこいつよちょっとさすがに取り込んでみますね
いきます
[拍手]
は
やばい
声ま
ポッパ
んをっ
ん
買ったこれは勝ちましたわ弥永圧縮されてるんで
沈みかんだがどうなるのかなと思ったんですけども完全にそうな見せるソファーと一緒
です
もうふかふかの僕も普段これよこれやばいこれやばいぞこれヤバイぞ
コーリャいや保育テクスチャーこれ
になった決めたは王になった気分コースねこれは着みてください困難にいけない部屋に
ある
5つな物資部でがすげってよもう
くっショットが置いたらこの際ではもう
[音楽]
はいという議題1を試せるぞあの世界最大9面を買ってみたんですけども
またが僕が見えた切りこれが今のところ世界で一番大きいとダミーするソファーでした
めちゃまだなん
me
うううう
あっはぁ